wie heißen sie
ich heiße giulia monti
woher kommen sie woher kommen sie
ich komme aus italien ich komme aus
italien
wie heißen sie ich heiße juli macht
woher kommen sie
ich komme aus frankreich hallo ich heiße
artisow hatte ich komme aus indonesien
hallo ich heiße wann pablo garcía
ich komme aus mexiko hallo ich heiße
eicher kariya ich komme aus marokko
hallo ich heiße asche bat ich komme aus
indien
hallo ich heiße sofia braun ich komme
aus den usa
hallo ich heiße london
ich komme aus china
hallo ich heiße erichsen ich komme aus
schweden
guten tag ich heiße angelo ich komme aus
brasilien
auf guten tag wie heißen sie berührt sie
ich heiße peter müller
woher kommen sie ich komme aus südafrika
wo wohnen sie
wo wohnen sie ich wohne in johannesburg
ich wohne in johannesburg welche sprache
sprechen sie welche sprache sprechen sie
ich spreche afrikaans ich spreche
afrikaans ich wohne in zürich ich wohne
in lugano
ich wohne in genf ich spreche
italienisch ich spreche deutsch ich
spreche französisch wie heißen sie
ich heiße maria alvarez alvarez
buchstabieren sie bitte lvz
ach so alvarez
und ich heiße absehbar war wie
buchstabieren sie bitte ich heiße bsk
kvv woher kommen sie
ich komme aus kenia und sie
woher kommen sie ich komme aus spanien
welche sprache sprechen sie in kenia
kenianisch sprechen sie portugiesisch
nein ich spreche nicht portugiesisch ich
spreche spanisch ich wohne hier in
zürich wo wohnen sie
wie österreich wie südafrika wie ägypten
wie schweden wie spanien die schweiz wie
griechenland wie china wie honduras wie
philippinen wie deutschland
guten tag nehmen sie platz
danke was kann ich für sie tun
ich möchte mich in der schweiz anmelden
wie ist ihr vorname mein vorname ist
daniel wie ist ihr nachname mein
nachname ist smith
wie ist ihre adresse meine adresse ist
hohe straße 7
was ist ihr wohnort mein wohnort ist
zürich
wie ist ihre telefonnummer meine
telefonnummer ist 07 86 23 195 4 0 0 1 1
2 2 3 3 445 56 67
78 89 9 10 10 11 11 12 12 meine
telefonnummer ist 07 6 294 58 12 meine
telefonnummer ist 04 35 69
1782 guten tag wie ist ihr vorname
ich heiße für o mine
wie schreibt man das buchstabieren sie
bitte fnp
[Musik]
danke wie ist ihr nachname hmm ja
richtig wie ist ihre adresse deutsch
straße 9
was ist ihr wohnort wo wohnen sie mein
wohnort ist luzern
ich wohne in luzern was ist ihre
herkunft woher kommen sie
ich komme aus kamerun
was ist ihre muttersprache meine
muttersprache ist französisch wie ist
ihre telefonnummer meine telefonnummer
ist 04 13 752 893 hallo
wie heißt du ich heiße manfred und du
ich heiße petra woher kommst du ich
komme aus england
wo wohnst du ich wohne in basel
welche sprache sprichst du ich spreche
englisch
hallo wie ist ein vorname mein vorname
ist magnus lgs ja richtig und wie ist
dein nachname mein nachname ist nilsson
das schreibt man nsn danke wie ist deine
adresse
meine adresse ist abend straße 3 abend
straße 3 ja genau hier im ziel ich ja
ich wohne in zürich was ist deine
herkunft woher kommst du ich komme aus
norwegen
und was ist deine muttersprache meine
muttersprache ist norwegisch wie ist
deine telefonnummer
meine telefonnummer ist 07 66 98 23 41
hallo ich heiße ericsson
ich bin 29 jahre alt ich komme aus
schweden und wohne in bern
ich spreche schwedisch englisch und ich
lerne deutsch ich bin ledig
ich bin ledig ich arbeite als architekt
ich arbeite als architekt hallo ich
heiße party suharto ich komme aus
indonesien
ich bin 34 jahre alt meine muttersprache
ist indonesisch ich spreche auch noch
englisch und ich lerne deutsch
ich wohne in luzern und arbeitet als
krankenpflegerin
ich bin verheiratet
hallo ich heiße peter meyer
das ist meine familie
ich habe zwei kinder
mein sohn heißt michael er ist zwölf
jahre alt meine tochter heißt anna sie
ist neun jahre alt
sie tanzt gern und das ist meine frau
sie heißt stephani sie arbeitet als
kassiererin
hallo ich heiße anna maier
ich bin neun jahre alt das ist meine
familie
das sind meine eltern sie sind
verheiratet
mein vater heißt peter er arbeitet als
polizist
das ist meine mutter sie heißt stefanie
das ist mein bruder
er heißt michael er spielt gern fußball
wie alt sind sie wie alt sind sie wie
alt bist du
wie alt bist du ich
in 29 jahre alt ich bin 29 jahre alt 10
11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27
28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40
50 60 70
80 90 62 45 sind sie verheiratet sind
sie verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
ich bin ledig ich bin ledig
[Musik]